docteur anne bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors hier le professeur jean françois
delfraissy a qualifié de difficile voire
critique la situation au niveau national
une deuxième vague probablement plus
forte que la première
quelle est la situation dans votre
service de réanimation dans le service
de réanimation à l'hôpital raymond
poincaré
la situation est très tendue depuis
presque deux semaines maintenant ou
fonctionnant avec la capacité pleine
tous nos lits sont occupés tous les
jours et donc nous refusons
régulièrement tous les jours plusieurs
patients qu'ils soient atteints de la
cabine 19 ou atteints d'autres
pathologies qui nécessitent des soins de
réanimation
pourquoi jusqu'à aujourd'hui voilà les
lits qui avait été promis après la
première vague ne sont toujours pas là
est ce que finalement le gouvernement
n'a pas anticipé ou a pris à la légère
voilà aller
les sos qui avait été lancé par les
personnels soignants en disant attention
il y aura une deuxième vague est clair
qu' il y a eu du retard pris à
reconnaître l'apparition de la deuxième
vague vers la fin du mois d'août
et puis ensuite un retard également à
reconnaître que cette deuxième bague
allait être plus importante que la
première au sens où il y aurait
davantage de patients à prendre en
charge en secteur hospitalier et en
particulier en secteur de réanimation et
du fait aussi qu'il y aurait beaucoup
moins de personnel soignant mobilisables
qu'en mars et avril
en effet aujourd'hui on voit
difficilement comment augmenter le
nombre de lits de réanimation si l'on
n'a pas les renforts humains de
personnel soignant compétent pour
prendre en charge les patients en
réanimation facteurs limitants et la
réalité il ya évidemment le souci de ces
lits qui manque aujourd'hui dans les
hôpitaux
il ya aussi le problème du personnel
soignant qui en sous-effectif qui reste
malgré tout mobiliser aujourd'hui quel
est leur état d'esprit
l'état d'esprit d'espagne ont il est
effectivement une très forte
mobilisation beaucoup de d'infirmières
d'aides-soignantes de deux médecins ont
choisi de ne pas prendre de congés à
tout ça compte tenu du contexte
épidémique est de rester donc mobilisé
de rester sur le bon malgré la fatigue
malgré l'épuisement physique et moral et
mental et aussi avec une certaine
frustration sur finalement la
frustration de se retrouver à nouveau
dans cette situation tendue et critique
alors qu'on avait le sentiment qu'on
aurait pu prévenir ou en tout cas faire
en sorte qu'elle soit que la situation
soit moins critique
si on m'avait agi plus tôt l'exécutif a
instauré un couvre-feu
le 17 octobre qui est aujourd'hui
étendue à 54 départements les effets de
ce couvre feu
seront visibles quand le couvre feu
n'est rien d'autre qu'un confinement
partiels dans la journée et on voit
après une dizaine presque dix jours
maintenant de au film en partiel que la
dynamique épidémique c'est à dire la
pente d'accélération de la propagation
du virus est véritablement très
importante elle ne faiblit pas après dix
jours de couvre feu on peut les très
probables coup le couvre-feu et aucun
impact sur la propagation du virus pour
la célérité tels que notre structure nos
structures hospitalières pourrait être
totalement débordé dans les dix quinze
jours qui viennent qu'est ce qui est
différent actuellement par rapport à la
première vague a qu'on a vécu au
printemps
alors il y à de nombreuses différentes
les plus importantes sont que au
printemps le confinement des réussi à
circonscrire l'épidémie à un grand quart
nord-est savait donc permis de faire
face à la bague grâce aux renforts venus
de régions aux transferts de patients
aujourd'hui c'est toute la france un qui
est concerné le virus est hyper
endémique et donc il n'y a plus de zone
de territoire protégé ce qui limite
considérablement les possibilités de
renfort et de redéploiement des
personnels et sa limite également
considérablement les possibilités de
transferts de patients enfin le contexte
est différent puisque l'arrêt de la
saison automne hiver est une saison qui
est très propice ou des compensations
des maladies chroniques et aux
nombreuses surge ans et on le voit bien
de notre système de santé est
extrêmement sollicité par des
pathologies qui ne sont pas liées à la
copie 19 phénomène que nous n'avions pas
en mars avril et donc on pouvait se
concentrer uniquement sur la cabine 19
aujourd'hui la situation est très
différent l'acolyte 19 n'est qu'un
élément n'est qu'un facteur parmi les
nombreux facteurs qui met en temps sur
notre système hospitalier
l'heure est à l'urgence également pour
le chef de l'état emmanuel
acro qui va réunir aujourd'hui demain
des conseils de défense un durcissement
des mesures sanitaires semble inévitable
alors plusieurs scénarios sont sur la
table on parle d'un couvre-feu plus dur
qui commencerait peut-être à 19 heures
il y à quelques temps on voulait même
pas parler de confinement aujourd'hui
cette option est également sur la table
un confinement doit-il être mise en
place afin de soulager les hôpitaux
selon vous le confinement est la seule
solution réaliste
le couvre-feu élargi aurait été une
solution il ya quinze jours trois
semaines
aujourd'hui cette solution là est
dépassé donc le confinement la seule la
seule solution réaliste
après leur confient ne veut pas dire se
remettre dans la même situation qu'en
mars à oopa faut tenir compte des leçons
tirées au film en 2 mars pour réduire au
maximum l'impact négatif social et
économique dure confinement et il ya
plein de mesures qui peuvent être prises
pour permettre une efficacité sanitaire
tout en maintenant des activités
socioculturelles tout en maintenant la
possibilité d'accéder à l'école
notamment pour les les personnes issues
des milieux les plus précaires le
télétravail pour réduire au maximum les
déplacements dans le cadre professionnel
sans trop impacter l'activité économique
et des entreprises
oui c'est tout à fait envisageable de
confiner très rapidement et dès
maintenant avec toute une série de
mesures qui visent à atténuer les effets
négatifs du confinement
merci beaucoup djillali annane d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chef du service de réanimation
à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches